المواجهات العنيفه بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والقوات الروسيه مستمره واكثرها ضراوه تلك
التي تدور في مدينه بخموت في منطقه
دوناتسك حيث تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه
الدفاع ببساله عن هذه المدينه من داخلها
رغم الهجوم المدفعي والبري عليها من قبل
القوات الروسيه المعارك تدور في المدينه
والعدو يواجه صعوبات اكبر انها المره
الاولى التي نشهد فيها المعارك تدور في كل
شارع من المدينه والناس يتقبلون ذلك بشكل
طبيعي ولديهم دوافع جيده الوضع صعب على
العدو لان لواءنا موجود داخل المدينه
والروس ينتشرون في الحقول مذعورين
الناس الاوكرانيه
واشاد بالجنود الاوكرانيين الذين يتمسكون
بقوه بالدفاع عن هذا الحصن واشار الى بقعه
ساخنه اخرى
جنوب بخموت حيث يشن الروس هجوما عنيفا
ايضا علينا ان الربيع هناك شعور حقيقي بان
اوكرانيا تتجه نحو النصر يعتمد الامر على
اعداد قواتنا الدفاعيه وتزويد دولتنا
بالسلاحي وعلى مبادرتنا الاستراتيجيه في
الحرب اي محاوله روسيه لاستعاده المبادره
يجب كسرها انا متاكد من اننا سنفعل ذلك
العدو يفقد فعليا الكثير من رجاله والكثير
من قواده
روسيا تفقد عددا من رجالها واوكرانيا ايضا
اكثر من مدينه اوكرانيه مثل الفيف تشيع
ضحايا العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا من
الجنود الذين قضوا ولا يزالون في ريعان
الشباب